when an anomaly is first detected by an
scp foundation field agent
it's up to the foundation's mobile task
forces to tag and bag the impossible
entities before they can do any more
harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times
not so much especially when they're
dealing with brutal forces of nature
like scp-096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first
interaction with the foundation had a
reputation for being dangerous
and needed to be feared a series of
vague sightings and mysterious
disappearances
up in the frosty mountains of the yukon
first sparked the foundation's interest
when they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams
zulu9a and zulu9b were dispatched to
secure and contain the entity
zulu9a took the lead in a heavy duty
chopper equipped with 50 caliber gau-19
heavy machine guns
and carrying an at4 anti-tank launcher
they were prepared for anything or so
they thought
as they established a visual on scp-096
while two clicks away from the target
they couldn't get a clear line of sight
on the creature but it appeared to be
stationary
docile and was making no attempt to flay
a piece of cake right
little did they know that scp-096 was
just looking away from them
if it was facing towards them it'd be a
whole different
horror story as zulu9a were about to
find out
the team landed their helicopter next to
the creature and were shocked to see
that it was completely naked
in spite of the subzero temperatures all
around them the creature was unnaturally
thin
as though it had been starved for weeks
with bone white skin and unnaturally
long limbs
the team guessed that the creature's
arms must have been at least 1.5 meters
long
but its docile nature and insubstantial
body mass gave the impression that it
wouldn't prove too difficult to contain
that is until they saw its face
zulu 9a's captain was the lone survivor
of the incident
as he was lucky enough to be looking
away when the creature turned towards
his team
the rest of the squad ended up staring
eye to eye with scp-096
and from that moment on wasn't docile
anymore
the creature began to whimper then cry
then
sob uncontrollably in a way that sounded
eerily human
this sudden change in temperament
startled the rest of zulu 9a
and they opened fire on the creature
under the hail of gunfire
scp-096 entered a murderous frenzy
and began tearing into the hapless squad
of soldiers while its flesh and organs
did seem to take damage as a result
of the barrage of 50 caliber rounds from
the helicopter mounted machine guns
its skeletal structure remained intact
and it continued its onslaught
tearing the team limb from limb even
after they blown
practically all the flesh from the
creature the at4 anti-tank launcher
proved equally ineffective at stopping
scp-096 while it was in attack mode
and it was only after slaughtering the
entire team that it returned to its
docile state
nobody knows exactly what the creature
did to zulu 9a after the gunfire started
but no trace of the team was left behind
zulu 9b touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face
they were finally able to subdue it a
bag was placed over scp-096's face
which seemed to soothe it enough to move
it to a nearby foundation facility
little did they know they just obtained
one of the deadliest scps of all time
and while it may have been under lock
and key for now it seemed inevitable
that it would get out and cause more
violence and chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of dr dan
a senior researcher at the site it was
his job to find out exactly what this
being was capable of
the more he tested the more he realized
that they were dealing with something
truly
terrifying disposable d-class personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its attack mode
just as it had during the initial
retrieval mission scp-096 went berserk
when any of the attending personnel saw
its face
in this stage it would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes
covering its face and wailing loudly
when the period of distress
ended the creature would mercilessly
slaughter every d-class that had seen
its face
and just like with zulu 9a no trace of
their bodies would be
left behind dr den was horrified and
intrigued by this phenomenon
the creature killed anyone that saw its
face directly but could the same be said
for indirect depictions of the
creature's face
such as images and videos dr dan was
desperate to find out
more d-class personnel were brought in
to test this to frightening results
dr dan found that the creature did
indeed still enter attack mode when
people saw pictures and videos of
scp-096's face
the creature seemed to have an innate
sense of when people were viewing these
representations
even when it should have had no
conceivable way of knowing
it didn't matter how far away or how
many barriers were in place between the
viewer and the creature
the attack mode would still activate and
once it did
it seemed as though nothing could stop
the creature from hunting down the one
who saw its face
with all this new data special
containment procedures were devised to
keep the creature
safely under lock and key its cell was a
five meter by five meter by five meter
airtight steel cube
fitted with advanced pressure sensors
and laser detectors to ensure that
scp-096 remained in its cell
without risking anyone having visual
contact with the creature's face
all cameras and video equipment were
strictly forbidden and weekly checks for
any cracks or holes in the containment
cell were mandatory
of course none of this would stop the
creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem dr
dan would need to continue his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance
they needed to know exactly what they
were dealing with but how could they
when even a glance at a photo or video
of the being meant certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face
something that hadn't yet been attempted
but how would they achieve such a fee
simple they'd procure a d-class prisoner
with some artistic talent
and they found one who had been a tattoo
artist before becoming a foundation
guinea pig
dr dan formulated an ingenious plan for
keeping this d-class alive for long
enough to accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face
he would be placed in a bathysphere
diving bell several kilometers
underwater
and tens of kilometers away from the
containment cell where the scp was being
held
the d-class was made to look at a
photograph of the creature's face
and then replicate that image in a
pencil sketch
dr dan first confirmed that the
creature's attack mode is only activated
by the creature's face
by having the d-class look at a series
of photos of the scp's body parts
one by one finally finishing with its
face
the d-class began drawing and even
remarked on how creepy the scp's facial
features were
despite not knowing the deadly context
meanwhile
back in its containment cell scp-096
sent someone viewing its face
and entered its inconsolable crying
state followed by its attack mode
it broke out of containment easily and
began making a beeline for the d-class
traversing the miles between it and its
prey the d-class didn't know it as he
locked the finished drawing into a
separate
autonomous submersible but he was
already dead
as the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface scp-096 dived
into the water
and started swimming down towards the
artist minutes later
the bathysphere was breached and the
d-class
was torn to shreds scp-096 was
recaptured without issue by surface
recovery team foxtrot 303a
and further testing on the drawing
showed that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience we now know that
the creature has a god face with totally
white eyes
possibly indicating blindness and a
grossly extended jaw
nevertheless dr dan was adamant that
scp-096 was too dangerous to be left
alive
and requested permission from the upper
echelons of the foundation
to terminate the creature by any means
necessary
however the doctor's request would fall
on deaf ears
until it all started with a seemingly
innocent image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the black speck inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096
taken unknowingly in the 1990s by a
semi-professional mountaineer
one day they were looking at old
photographs when his eyes passed over
the tiny speck without
even noticing that he had seen anything
but scp-096 noticed
and began entering its attack mode it
tore through its steel containment unit
like tissue paper
causing the release of a nerve agent
that killed a number of attending
foundation staff
the monster then fled the base and began
pursuing its prey with mobile task force
tau 1 in hot pursuit
dr alexey who was helping to manage the
site where the scp was contained
was in dismay over the situation dr dan
was out of the country at the time
trying to discover more about the
creature's origins however
he did leave the mobile task force with
a new secret weapon against the
rampaging shy guy
project scramble scramble were
state-of-the-art goggles featuring a new
technology created by dr
dan which using artistic renditions of
096's facial features
could detect and scramble the features
of scp-096 into an unrecognizable form
preventing the normally deadly effect of
gazing upon its face
in theory this would allow mtf tau1 to
engage safely with 096 once its prey had
been eliminated and bring it back into
containment
but disaster struck on two fronts first
the prey in question was located in a
population center
creating the potential for a huge loss
of life and the second bigger problem
was that the scramble technology didn't
work
as stray pixels of the creature's face
would reach the eyes of the task force
before the internal microprocessor had
time to scramble them
the mission turned into a death sentence
as scp-096
slaughtered almost the entire task force
as well as a number of civilians in town
including an infant and its entire
family it was a monumental disaster
made even worse by a final revelation dr
dan and dr alexi had themselves
facilitated the entire containment
breach
and allowed the resulting massacre to
happen with dr dan hoping it would be
enough motivation for foundation command
to green light his
research into destroying the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing
would be worth the bloodshed his plan
worked and the scp foundation
saw it his way approving his request to
neutralize scp-019
however success comes at a cost for dr
dan
once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature
though done in his line of duty he
himself will be terminated by the
foundation for his crimes against
humanity
but considering how much damage scp-096
is capable of causing if it ever got to
a major population center
or even worse was ever caught on camera
and broadcast to a worldwide audience
the doctor himself would likely deem his
own death a justifiable cost
to this day the foundation is
researching ways to kill the creature
and they're still looking for their
silver bullet and the pressure is on
they hadn't known about the seemingly
innocent picture that sparked the last
containment breach
the one taken decades ago in which the
shy guy had only occupied
four tiny pixels four tiny pixels that
resulted in multiple innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking out there
photos with an innocent dot in the
background your eyes glance over it
not even noticing the little blip until
you hear
a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer
and closer and closer
and then it's already too late
you